thank you and good morning
so
this is a talk about spectral geometry
and um a spectral geometry of course
means relating the geometry of a space
in in today's talk it's going to be a
graph with weights on the edges but the
techniques go over to quite general
spaces
to something like the eigen
the spectra the eigenvalues eigenvectors
of something like the laplacian and uh
and
it goes both ways um
in statistical application spectral
clustering which is one of the themes of
this week
people try to look at
well the eigenvectors and try to learn
something about the geometry of the
space and i'm going to be using the
geometry of the space to understand
something about the spectrum but it it
it really does go both ways
the
the
new thing today the reason i'm giving
this talk is that
we have a lot of insight and experience
with geometric methods
and there are some different operators
uh not just the laplacian where the
methods still are effective can be
effective and and
there's a lot to do in trying to push
that forward so let me begin by
reminding you
what the
what kind of one classical
use of spectra is
what i call the geometric theory of
markov chains so if x is a finite set
and uh
pi of x
is a probability distribution
and if
you have a markup chain
so the transition matrix of a markov
chain
and i'm going to suppose it's reversible
so you could think of a graph in which
the vertices are x
and uh there's an edge from x to y if k
x y is positive and then you put this
weight on the edges and then i'm going
to be talking about doing the random
walk on the graph so if you're at a
vertex pick one of your nearest
neighbors with probability proportional
to its weight and go there
i think about it
this way but it's the same process
because of this symmetry because of this
reversibility
there are eigen there's a basis of
eigenfunctions
so there exists
phi i
uh eigenfunctions such that
k
phi
i is
beta i
phi i of x
here i use the notation
k f and x
it's just column vectors is the sum
of k of x y
um
f of y
so there is an orthonormal basis of
eigen
functions uh and and eigenvalues real
spectrum and and then you can get your
hands on the rates of convergence uh if
k l if k squared of x y
is the sum of k of x y x z uh k
of z
y
and so if if you divine
you know it's the product of the matrix
square of the matrix or
from
everybody knows uh this is a sum in z uh
then you can get your hands on uh the
distance to stationarity uh
and i'll i'll use this total variation
distance uh which is
well one half the sum of uh k l of x y
minus pi of y
um here's some over y and should have an
x in it because keep track of where you
started so one would like to answer the
question given epsilon bigger than zero
how lord should l be so that this is
small and you can get your hands on that
using the this bound uh
i want to bound this thing
and so i can bound it square
take square roots later
this is less than or equal to the sum
over i equals
1 to the
space of
the
the zeroth eigen function is 1 of
beta i the eigenvalue to the 12th power
times phi i of x
squared so this is a basic this is the
koshi schwarz uh inequality this is the
basic geometric bound which says that if
you know about the eigenvalues you could
know about the rates of convergence
sometimes uh uh we
use a crude upper bound on this uh
it's less than or equal to the
spectral the second the second
eigenvalue divided by pi of x uh
um and so if we can bound the second
eigenvalue and if we know something
about the stationary distribution we can
know something about uh convergence so
that's um
that's
all
now classical and um uh but
now the work starts given some actual
markup chain and then you have to get
your hands on this and try to get your
hands on these and
and then do the analysis and that that
that's a job i mean that's
okay so
the the new so the first new problem uh
it was new to me uh
is absorbing markov chains
and
quasi stationarity
and
so just as a as a picture uh picture a
graph here's just here some graph and
there's some bad part on the boundary
and uh maybe here it's just you know
here if you hit you go back just the
usual way but here if you hit you stop
and uh and and so
you stop eventually if the graph is
connected it's an absorbing markov chain
and um there are there's lots of that
around uh i wasn't so aware of it and i
ran into it in some applied problems and
then
then it's natural to ask
well you know what can you say
along these lines about an absorbing
markov chain and examples are coming in
a second okay um
and uh so first let me introduce some
notation if i write down here can people
see it is it still okay
yes okay good
so let me introduce some notation um
i'm going to lump
for now i'm going to lump all of the
absorbing states into one state you
won't lose too much which i'm going to
call infinity
that's
okay and then i've got a matrix
which here uh here's infinity and so if
you hit infinity you stay there
okay
but of course you can get to infinity so
there's some a1
maybe up to a n
this is my matrix k k i j now but
and here is some
n minus 1 by you know here's some big
block uh you know what's left of k just
not at infinity and um uh so
you know this
this is the chance of going from j
to infinity this this entry and so
what you observe is that this q
is a a positive matrix non-negative
matrix and um therefore by prone
forbanius uh uh there
there exists um uh phi of x
and psi of x
and
beta all bigger than zero these are
functions uh uh i'm going to assume q is
connected uh that you can get from any
place to any place else such that uh uh
this is a such that phi
q is equal to beta
um
phi and uh
q psi
is equal to uh beta psi so these are the
prone eigenvectors of this uh matrix q
and um
they they exist
and
let me tell you what they mean um uh so
that will be important
and okay
so there there are left and right
eigenvectors and a positive eigenvalue
beta so what do they mean
well
look at
q
to the l power
and look at the x y
entry
first of all what is that it's the sum
over all paths going from x to y and l
steps which don't ever hit infinity
right so
got a very simple interpretation and
this converges of course to uh to um to
to the left
to phi
uh of y
and let me normalize it by uh so that it
becomes a probability q
x and that converges to
phi bar where here i use the notation q
bar of x to be
the sum in y of uh q
l uh
l
l
of x y so that's this is just the chance
of not being absorbed all
after l steps and five r is the
normalizing constant here phi bar
is
just the sum
of an x and y of x
so
this is just
elementary and
what this says is that
if you run what this says i'll write it
down various ways what this says is if
you run the chain a long time and you
haven't died
you can ask where are you likely to be
that's what this means this is called
the quasi-stationary distribution okay
so it's it so if in probabilistic
language if t
is the
he's a is the first time you hit
infinity
is equal to the first time
infinity um this says that the
probability
that the markov chain started at x uh
is equal to y
uh at time t uh given that capital t is
bigger than t
uh converges to uh uh this phi
of y over phi bar
and
as t goes to infinity and so that's uh
i'll give examples in a second but that
that's what the the left eigen
vector means what does beta mean um
uh
so
this beta mean uh
beta um
it's the absorption time but there's a
nice
interpretation of it directly uh you can
look at this
what's the probability uh given that you
started
at this quasi-stationary distribution
just to make something precise uh given
that you started at phi over phi bar
okay so you pick your starting state
from this measure
we can also do it starting from a point
what's the probability given that you
started from there that capital t is
bigger than
little t
that's exactly equal to no asymptotics
beta to the little t
so that tells you what beta means in a
sort of direct probabilistic way uh
and uh what does the right eigenvector
mean um
i'll tell you that too um
and this is just all
you know prone for it for manias and and
thinking in a kind of an applied way uh
uh what does the right eigenvector mean
well if you
okay this has a fancy name but i won't
if you look at this matrix uh q
x y and then multiply it by psi of um y
and then divide it by uh psi of x
and times theta
okay so that's a new matrix um
this matrix is stochastic if you sum
this in y
okay
because this is a right eigenvector you
get
beta times psi of x and you get one
right so this is a stochastic matrix
it has a name it's called the dew
transform
and what it means is it's the law of the
markov chain given that it's never
absorbed
and and so you know maybe somebody tells
you or i can condition it makes sense to
say well i'm running this chain and it
never got absorbed
how does it go and
this is uh this is again a markup chain
and it's it it's very closely connected
to to quasi stationary distributions and
um it has as a stationary distribution
again these are very easy facts uh uh
phi of x times psi of x
and then normalized times phi sine
r and you can just see that if you
multiply this on the left by phi psi and
then sum it you know that this cancels
and you have a left eigenvector and it's
okay you know just trivial what i'm
saying everything i'm saying is easy so
um uh
is there some additional assumption
you're making on cube without assuming
that
not really i mean you mean
something about parity or something like
that i mean like imagine that the market
changes a directed path that that's
infinity
then with really one you are absorbed in
the final time
no well yes but i'm
yes but i'm conditioning i'm here i'm
can
first of all forget forget anything this
is a stochastic matrix this matrix
the equation on the top of the right
this
so this is the you have non-zero
probability of
this is i think this is true just under
connectivity but i'm and i'm starting
from the stationary distribution it's
this is again it's an algebraic
verification i don't i don't think uh
that is of course with probability one
you know this beta is less than one
so with probability
of length three that answered
then the probability of yeah capital t
is more than four is zero but i'm i'm
assuming well i'm in the reversible case
i'm in the reversible case
but how can an absorbing markov chain be
reversible
oh it's a it's reversible on the sorry
it's reversible on the non-absorbing
states i see so q is reversible right
that that most
yes
for this interpretation q is reversible
k is
well okay i didn't say that good i i i'm
going to assume it
you don't need that
but
okay i'm i haven't gotten even started
but thank you for listening uh but so
that but but so these are i try to tell
you what what the eigenvalues and the
eigenfunctions mean
now
when you see this kind of thing
uh if you're me uh it's natural to ask
for quantitative theory
so
uh by thinking of just the heat equation
and a boundary condition you could if
you like that language
no but isn't identical or not but what
if you have a domain in rn i mean it's
not identical these are matrices young
men
so uh if you have a domain in rn and if
you and if you have brownian motion in
the domain
then
i don't know about wires gary
i don't know about wires i and i don't
so if you have a domain in rn and if you
have brownian motion in the domain then
the the this is the dirichlet
eigen function if you vanish on all of
the boundary and that has the
interpretation as if you've been running
brownian motion for a long time and it
hasn't been absorbed where is it likely
to be and that's what that's what phi is
and that would be the first set of
eigenvectors you found right that's the
first
left eigenvector
the well is a left eigenvector and a
right eigenvector
and
good
thank you
okay so it's natural to try to think
about a quantitative version of these
things
and um here it comes
so
so
additional distribution even that you
didn't absorb for time t does it english
that's t that's just what i'm about to
say thank you hi and good morning
friends in the audience
so a natural question
if you're
many of the people in this audience is
uh
uh
how large
kb
so that i'll write it this way that the
probability starting at x
uh that uh xk
uh
you know is contained in
dot i mean the probability distribution
given that t is bigger than k
minus this phi
over phi bar the quasi stationary
distribution say in total variation
distance is less than epsilon
that is i know that as k goes to
infinity this probability distribution
converges to this probability
distribution and you can ask about you
know how large when does this when do
these asymptotics kick in
and uh that's uh and i was thought well
there'll be a there's a giant literature
on quasi stationarity i mean you know
books
you know
hundreds and thousands of papers
that's a natural question and and it
seems to have not ever been addressed
essentially uh so everything i'm going
to tell you now is from a
technical report with laurent nicklow
and it's on my homepage and on the
archive
and it's rates of convergence to quasi
stationarity and let's see what i'm
gonna tell you because
i had to make some choices and uh
oh first thing is an example
that's always good and uh okay so
example
just you know
what does a theorem look like suppose
that i just have a path as luca was
saying
and it's
go this way but here's you die when you
hit that and here's n okay
it's a path of length n
and i just i'm doing simple random walk
and
so there's a quasi stationarity and one
of the questions is what are quasi
stationary distributions look like how
can you get your hands on them how can
you understand them
here the quasi-stationary distribution
phi
of x
here's uh i'll call this 0 1 up to n
is equal to there's a normalizing
constant which we know
times
cosine
why should i make it up when i wrote it
down i read my own writing um
uh
two n plus one oh no two
yeah two n plus one
minus two x
times i i'll draw a picture which is
really what's needed uh over twice uh
two
n minus one
and so the the picture is uh here's zero
here's n uh the picture is
just like this
so
you've been you've been wandering around
for a long time uh it doesn't matter
this is a limiting theorem you've been
wandering around for a long time
you die if you're at zero if you hit
zero where are you likely to be and the
answer is you're kind of here okay and
and
but but this is exactly the answer and
um as a theorem about you know rates of
convergence how long does it take until
this is usefully close suppose you start
here uh
theorem uh if
n is bigger than there's a constant
which i actually also wrote down uh
s times 5 over two pi squared uh
times n squared uh
starting it in uh starting at n
then uh this this distance uh this
distance uh is less than or equal to e
to the minus s
and so uh and there's a matching lower
bound
on the left-hand side
this is
this in this is
this is k
thank you
this is this k how many steps you're
right thank you thank you right so if
you go
a small multiple of n squared steps
these asymptotics are useful if you go a
small multiple of n squared
less you know with 10th n squared steps
this distance is is very far from from
from being small and sorry does it
depend upon
this particular it can really depend on
where you start this particular result
doesn't depend on where you start uh
but but
so but it can depend on where you start
and here i'm depending this particular
result it's also true even if you start
one away right
because i'm well the the actual
statement that i'm making um so
you now can see so you could ask you
know take any problem that you think you
know about take the hypercube take a
tree take anything
you die if you hit some vertices and
then do the random walk say anything
about the state quasi-stationary
distribution say anything about the rate
of convergence that's a class of
problems okay now there's many many
natural problems take the permutations
take random transpositions
you die
if you have a fixed point you know
something i mean
there are many many there are many many
ways of making questions and you'd have
to look so how are such theorems
proved uh
okay so here's a thing that i found
or disturbing or exciting doesn't depend
on how you want to phrase it um
in the first setting
ergodic markup chains we have many many
techniques for bounding the spectrum and
and proving theorems of of this sort uh
for ergotic chains
you know we can use a
poincare
cheeker
nash sober left inequalities
log sobel off
coupling
stationary times
paris recurrence techniques
okay there must be analogs of these
techniques in the set of problems i just
mentioned i don't know them i don't
think anybody knows them okay so that's
it
so let me tell you where we are because
we we just got started building a theory
and
i think there's plenty of things to do
for anybody who's interested
so
this is a
conference on on spectral geometry so
i'm going to take a spectral geometric
approach
so
here's a spectral
geometry approach
and i should say i'm not
doing it in this talk but the paper i
wrote with miklo has good pointers to
what's the literature on quasi
stationarity it's it's a healthy big
literature it just doesn't it's just not
quantitative um but they do there's a
lot of interesting things that are done
there okay so spectral geometry so
let me
assume
uh that uh q is reversible with respect
to something uh in this example q is
the q matrix is symmetric so say
um that
uh there exists q of x
bigger than zero such that q x
q x y
is equal to
y
um
q
y x and and in in our example this q in
that example it's symmetric but
otherwise you
want to allow that
um so suppose that's the case uh our
paper is written without that assumption
but
let me assume it for for now um and
connected this this is connected
so now this is the undirected case and
you know what i mean by connected and um
uh
then there is a um then there are well
there's a dirichlet form uh so
let me let l two of q just be equal to
the set of all uh the set of all
functions for
f from uh
x
from
from
i want to call it
let me suppose that x is s union
infinity
okay the the non-absorbing states are
called s and uh f from s into
c or r say r uh
um
uh
with uh with the q in you know just the
with uh the norm of f
uh sub q squared is the sum of f of x uh
q of x
makes this
and
if it comes up uh
uh uh if uh if if i write it and you get
nervous uh f of infinity uh extend uh
equals q of infinity equals zero if it
comes up okay so just
i don't wanna square on that
careful audience good um okay so there's
a dirichlet form and it
it took forever to get it right so it
seems trivial but it took forever to get
it right uh let e
ff this is the
appropriate quadratic form
to be one half
the sum
over x and y in x allowing infinity of f
of x uh minus f of y
uh squared times uh qx
times qxy
and so we think well wait a second
there are terms in here you know
if if one of them is infinity and one of
them isn't there are terms in here that
are that aren't that involve
this is a careful choice um there's
you can't do the more naive thing of
just summing over over s
okay so that's the dirichlet form and
fact one
uh
is that if
uh
there exists an a bigger than zero such
that
such that the l2 norm of f
squared
is less than or equal to a
times e
ff
so
for every f
then
theta
is less than or equal to 1 minus 1 over
a
of course that's that's the
variational characterization but
this
if you look it's a little it's
annoyingly tricky uh in any way it's
that that's a that's a easy to believe
fact and it's also true um and so okay
good uh of course we knew that in fact
too is we can bound it by geometry so
let's say that so uh fact two
um let's choose paths uh
for every x in s
uh let
gamma x and be equal to well x naught
which is x
x 1
x 2
up to x
l which is equal to uh
uh infinity so make a path in your graph
from x to infinity where the steps are
possible where uh q
x i
x i plus one is bigger than zero so
connect your point x to infinity and if
there's a lot of infinities there might
be
you're allowed to connect to any place
to any infinity so make a path that
connects you from a point to to infinity
and um the length of this path is l
and um
now there's a bound uh you can take a
this is a fact uh take a to be equal to
uh the maximum
uh over x contained in s
y contained in x allowing infinity of 1
over q of x
q of x y
times the sum
over z
such that x y
is contained in the path
c of the length of the path
times
q
so this is a geometric bound for people
who know about geometric theory of
markov chains um
these are the use of paths that that dan
struck started and and aleister sinclair
and
mark jerim
carried on with and
dan struck and i carried on with so this
is the path argument and um so these
kinds of if you haven't seen them it
looks impossible these kinds of
quantities can be usefully bounded and
you get a bound on on on the second
eigenvalue let me say one sentence about
the argument just so you see where this
condition comes from and then you'll say
oh it's the old argument and it is sort
of the old argument how does it work you
you write i i need to bound this l2 norm
so i'm going to write f of x
uh
f of x
as uh
well f of x
minus f of x1
plus
f of x1
minus f of x2
plus
f of
x l minus one
minus f of
x l
okay now that's
zero right that's zero and so this
collapses
and then just use koshi schwartz right
it's just the same the same now so the
square of this is less than or equal to
the length of this path times the sum of
squares and blah blah blah so
is that square
i haven't squared anything yet but if i
do uh
okay now use coaching schwartz
no
just about the line
where are you
where
a is equal to max of blah blah blah
f squared
no no no
but this isn't this is q
oh
many cases that cancels right
so
so
let me just go through this example just
so you can see uh what happens um just
so you see you can use this technique so
suppose i'm in this example okay so i've
got a i've got a point here there's only
one way to connect it to infinity just
connect it to infinity right just go
that way
there's nothing else you could do really
and what happens is um where's the edge
with the worst traffic it's this edge
right everything everything will cross
over that edge so that's the edge which
maximizes this bound and um
here
q of x y because you know these q's
cancel this q of x y is a constant it's
two this actually should be a two
uh sorry about that but it should be a
two and so this is a constant it's two
uh the chance of going left to right the
length of a path you know you know the
length of a path and so if you
use this argument um
you
uh
you get uh
um you get uh uh
you know in in the example
um
when i when i did it i think i got uh
four n times n plus 1 for a
you know you could just you know
these cancel this is a two the maximum
you know where it occurs you add up you
know
n minus i
and you get something of order n squared
and and it's this and
in this example we know because it's a
nice enough example so that you could
know uh what the eigenvalue is
uh and so and so we get you know an
honest pound so we get uh beta is less
than or equal to one minus one over
let me what did i actually
do okay actually when i did it this was
a two
i did my work so this is two uh
n times n plus one and and and here uh
actually actually beta one is equal to
some cosine of of some sort or other uh
cosine
of
pi over 2 n minus 1.
squared
over the terms and so you know the bound
is fine and people who have used pads
you can use them in very complicated
problems and get some information so
this is the start of of of path
technology and
there are many other problems
that we treat in the paper i want to
there's
there's the clock good i want to um i
want to tell you one other application
so i'm not going to do them but path
technology
is quite invol evolve
you can use randomized paths
uh
you can use weights and koshi schwartz
you can use local poincare
and
and we even have a way of doing in the
papers there we have a way of doing log
sobelef so uh uh
uh and so okay there's there's uh
that's a direction
okay so end of part one of the talk okay
luke is still awake he doesn't look so
awake but yes
slightly different questions so
is there computational complexity
in other words let's take a graph there
where the walk would be rapidly mixing
say a hypercube and now you now you put
in
you know say
a small number of things
and then you say
well
i want to know as far as the stationary
distribution goes what's the stationary
probability of the left sub-q of the
zero-sub-q could it be that this is hard
to approximately work sure it could be
um there's a there's a rich world and
i'm just it's not this talk but there's
a rich world of methods of approximating
the quasi-stationary distribution it's a
famous problem with lots of study let me
give you one example of an algorithm and
then analysis of this algorithm is
completely open research problem
people who actually do it's mostly in
biology that people study quasi-state
you know the creatures and if the if one
kind dies out they stay dead right so
you want to know how that evolves and so
um so one algorithm that's used uh to
to approximate quasi-stationary
distributions is start a thousand
markup chains at a thousand different
maybe all starting at the same point but
let them evolve independently
when one of them hits infinity of course
it dies but then what you do is pick one
that's alive and put at random and put
two points there
and then let them evolve independently
okay so that it's a theorem that process
that's now a you know a point you know
some particle process
that particle process converges to the
quasi-stationary distribution if you let
it run a long time the empirical measure
of the points that are alive is the
quasi-stationary distribution and
there's you know beautiful math
just improving that and getting started
but then to try to say something
quantitative so i'm sure there's a rich
world of questions of
how difficult is it to approximate quasi
stationarity and and i don't i think
nobody's thought about it so
thank you i'm i i have
i have one other problem that's
different but very related that i want
to tell you about or ask you about or
tell you about
and so i'm gonna do that uh and i'm
eager to hear ideas and suggestions but
i'm also eager to tell you this problem
so i'm going to do it
so let me begin with the actual
thing i
the actual matrix i want to bound so
what i just said is that you can apply
geometric techniques to positive
matrices where the rows are and all
don't sum to one to sub-stochastic
matrices that's all i just said okay
now i'm going to
do something else
here's a matrix i need to get my hands
on i'm going to call it m
and it's it's equal to this matrix
it's got a quarter here okay and it's n
by n
and above and below the diagonal
it's got ones
and uh it's got ones in the corner i'm
sorry to say and on the diagonal it's
got something it's 2 cosine
2 pi
j over n
and 0 less than or equal to j less than
or equal to n minus 1.
so can everybody see that matrix it's
constant above and below the diagonal it
undulates on the diagonal and it's got
these ones on the corner so
cosine is not positive so this isn't a
stochastic anything like a stochastic
matrix is negative there
the rows don't have a constant row sum
and i need to bound the biggest and the
smallest eigenvalues of that matrix and
i'd be very happy to have ideas i can do
this one i have many other matrices like
this
so what i want to do i will tell you
what this has to do with what i just
talked about i want to give you some
motivation for this so why am i doing
this and where does it come in
i will come back and bound that matrix
um
okay so motivation has to do with the
heisenberg group so let g
be equal to the set of all uh matrices
uh one one one zero here
x y z
so three by three upper triangular
matrices with x y and z contained in the
integers mod n
so that's a group uh uh the size of g is
n cubed
put anything in there it's uh it's
called the heisenberg group
brought in
and
of interest with elements in lots of
places but it's also of interest this is
also of of interest as i'll try to
explain so i'm going to write such an
element as xyz
and if you multiply two matrices
x prime y prime z prime
well that's equal to x plus x prime
y plus y prime
z plus z prime plus x y prime
multiply the matrices that's the product
in this group
and simple random walk on this group
is generated by picking one of these two
coordinates at random and making it plus
or minus one let's write that down let s
be my set of generators it's one zero
zero
minus one zero zero uh
zero one zero and zero minus one zero
those those generate the group and if i
let uh
q of g
be equal to uh one quarter if um g is
contained in s and zero otherwise that's
my random walk uh so each time you know
multiply pick one of the four matrices
at random multiply on the left and and
that converges certainly to the uniform
distribution as long as n is odd because
there's a parity problem otherwise you
could put the identity and if you like
um
but if n isn't odd then this converges
to uh
so q
this markov chain
q star k uh
g
and i want to know uh
how how fast this comes and if you're
not don't get nervous about groups it's
the you have a a
a graph the vertices are these matrices
you connect two if they differ by a
generator and then you're studying the
random walk on the cayley graph of that
group
and so one so i
there are many ways of approaching this
problem one that i always wanted to do
and i've just done and this is joint
work with dan bump
angela hicks
uh laurent nicklow
harold whitam
so it took a lot of us
to do this problem
it's natural to try to study random
walks on groups by using fourier
analysis and let me just say in a
sentence what that's about uh a
representation
of g
is a mapping rho from g into matrices
glv
uh with the property that rho of st
is rho of s
of t
so it takes
products into products um the fourier
transform
of a
of a probability
at a representation is the sum of q of g
times rho of g
so it's a matrix you just add up the
matrices and uh
and this thing is the fourier transform
uh at a certain irreducible
representation um
as usual uh
the
fourier transform
of a convolution
uh is the
q at rho
to the k power so fourier transform
takes
convolution into products the fourier
transform of the uniform distribution uh
you had a row
in an irreducible representation that's
not trivial is zero and so you study
rates of convergence of random walk to
their stationary distribution by
studying how fast these matrices
converge to zero and an effective way to
do that is this upper bound lemma uh the
distance of q star k
minus uh u
in total variation squared it's the same
upper bound lemma uh is less than or
equal to now here's the sum over row not
trivial of the dimension of rho uh times
uh the
formanius norm the trace norm of q hat
at rho um
2k power
so this is just the sum of the
eigenvalues if they're symmetric to
the 2k power um but i could put a 2k
inside this is an upper bound so where
this sum is over all irreducible
representations which are not trivial
and um so you have to get your hands on
these things for this group it's
actually
so if you do this over the integers just
over z
uh nobody knows the representations and
maybe you can prove if you like
complexity that nobody will ever know
seems to be a hard problem uh
for uh
uh for the energy is not in
oop that's not a good way to do it but
this will be better
it's harder
it's good exercise um for the integers
mod n
i can do it let me just tell you what it
is when n is a prime it's easier um but
it's
it's very similar
okay
i just didn't like being percy handled
so for
for
for our g
let me tell you what the
representations are
there and and n is prime
it's just easier i'm happy to tell you
offline if you want to know the rest um
uh so there are p squared one
dimensional representations
and p minus one uh
p dimensional
representations
let me tell you what they are uh so
rho sub a b of x y z
the index of representations is just uh
is just um
e to the 2 pi i
over p
times a x plus p y
just what i think it would be and here
um
for the p dimensional representations
let v be the set of all functions f
from uh z mod n z
into c
so just
vectors of length n and um uh
rho sub a uh a is now none zero mod p of
x y z
acts on a function f and its value at j
is something e to the 2 pi
i over p times a
times
don't tell me y times j
plus
z
times f of j plus x
so you act on functions by translating
by x and doing this uh multiplying by
that and you can easy to check that
those are representations a is anything
my p a and b can be anything and those
are all irreducible representations
okay so
that's classical and now i have to do
this when i do this
for well for the p dimensional represent
for the one-dimensional representations
it's just cosine there's no
no nothing new you have to do some
fourier analysis but uh uh for the
p-dimensional representations uh so
q-hat uh
at row of a
is a p by p matrix is uh
is equal to
just what i said one quarter
these are ones uh
and there's ones here and here is cosine
2 pi
a j over p
and so this matrix
has a natural story as if i have time it
has
well i don't have time so it has many
natural stories uh
okay
just uh
i was essentially over uh but let me
just tell you what's the connection
between the two parts of the talk um
so
i now need to bound the eigenvalues of
this of this matrix and um
well
so
first of all i can
i can make things positive by adding the
identity right so i plus m
what half i plus m
is now bigger than or equal to zero just
that makes things positive and then i
can
i can fix
and make something which has row sum
summing to one by appending infinity and
then uh
and then uh
uh well let's see
i think i think it's i think it's one
third i plus two-thirds uh
m
now is sub-stochastic
that is all the row sums are less than
or equal to one and so i i just
do this i make one uh here's zero
and and now here's my call this thing l
l is here
and
here's the cell and now i just put in
here whatever i need to make the row
sums one
and i think what these things are are uh
a j is equal to one third plus
two-thirds
uh
cosine uh
the
largest eigen value of this of course is
one from the absorbing state and the
second largest eigenvalue is the largest
eigenvalue of this matrix and now i can
use my geometric arguments and you can
show
it's not bad at all
a little bit of cleverness but
there's a little work to do of course
but you can show that beta
this beta which is the top eigen value
of this matrix is
1 minus
pi
over
2 um n
in general uh plus big o uh one over n
squared
and and
i also let me
so uh i can get my hands on the biggest
eigenvalue i can also get my hands on
the smallest eigenvalue and that needs
very different arguments using that
last line of the talk using that you can
show that if you run this random walk it
takes n squared steps to get random
that's necessary and sufficient
so time is over let me just say what
i've done
i've said
there are two problems i ran into where
i had matrices which were
not adjacency matrix of graphs but not
so far away from them one was quasi
stationarity where the where the
matrices are positive and sub-stochastic
and the second was this kind of matrix
and um and in both cases we could change
things around and
we're able to use the geometry of an
underlying graph in order to bound
spectra
i want to say one more thing which is
this matrix is a famous matrix it has a
hundred papers about it uh it it was one
of the reasons the last fields medal was
given uh just for people who care about
things like that uh uh it's it's often
it's called harper's operator uh it's
it's
the spectrum of this matrix is called
hofstadter's butterfly um and uh arthur
avila got the feels metal in part he did
many many wonderful things but for
solving what's called the ten martinis
problem and the ten martinis problem is
understanding the limiting spectra of
these matrices
without knowing that we rooted around
did our work and we know things that the
community doesn't know and seem
interested
so spectral geometry is still alive and
well it's time to stop